- [Instructor] Standard Cell Potential,
which is also called
Standard Cell Voltage,
refers to the voltage of
an electrochemical cell
when reactants and products
are in their standard states,
at a particular temperature.
For a zinc copper galvanic cell,
solid zinc reacts with
copper two plus ions,
to form solid copper,
and zinc two plus ions.
Standard Cell Potential
is symbolized by E naught
of the cell, where the superscript naught
refers to the fact that
reactants and products
are in their standard states.
For a solid, standard state
refers to the pure solid
under a pressure of one atmosphere.
So we're talking about pure solid zinc,
and pure solid copper.
And for a solution,
standard state refers to
a one molar concentration.
So our concentration of copper two
plus ions in solution is one molar,
and so is our concentration
of zinc two plus ions.
And for this zinc copper
cell, at 25 degrees Celsius,
the Standard Cell Potential is
equal to positive 1.10 volts.
Now that we've talked about
the Standard Cell Potential
for a zinc copper cell,
let's look at a diagram
of this galvanic cell.
For this cell, the anode
compartment contains
solid zinc metal, and
one molar concentration
of zinc two plus ions,
in aqueous solution.
The anode is where oxidation takes place.
So at the zinc electrode,
the solid zinc is converted
into zinc two plus ions,
and two electrons are lost.
So this is the oxidation
half reaction for this cell.
The electrons that are lost
in the oxidation half reaction
travel through the wire.
So there's a flow of electrons,
from the zinc electrode,
toward the copper electrode.
The cathode compartment
contains the solid copper
electrode and in solution,
one molar concentration
of copper two plus ions.
And the cathode is where
reduction takes place.
So at the surface of the copper electrode,
the copper two plus ions in solution
gain two electrons and
turn into solid copper.
So this is the reduction
half reaction for this cell.
If we were to attach a volt
meter to our two electrodes,
the volt meter would read 1.10 volts.
And this voltage is the
Standard Cell Potential.
So E naught of the cell
is equal to positive 1.10 volts.
And the Standard Cell Potential
depends on the potentials
for the two half reactions
that make up the cell.
So if we know the potentials
for the half reactions
that make up the cell,
we can calculate the standard potential
of any galvanic cell.
And let's see how we could do
that for this particular cell.
To calculate these standard cell potential
for our zinc copper cell,
we're going to use what are called
Standard Reduction Potentials.
Standard Reduction
Potentials are symbolized by
E naught of reduction.
And these refer to the voltages
for half reactions that are
written as reduction half reactions.
For example, if copper two plus
is reduced by two electrons
to form solid copper,
the voltage for this half reaction,
or the Standard Reduction Potential,
is equal to positive 0.34 volts.
And for the reduction
of zinc two plus ions
by two electrons to form solid zinc,
the Standard Reduction Potential
is equal to negative 0.76 volts.
We just saw from our
zinc copper cell diagram,
that copper two plus ions are reduced
to form solid copper.
So, we're going to leave this
half reaction as it's written.
However, in our diagram
for our zinc copper cell,
we saw that solid zinc was
actually being oxidized to form
zinc two plus ions.
So we need to rewrite
the second half reaction
as an oxidation half reaction.
And that just means reversing everything.
And if we're reversing our half reaction,
we have to change the sign on the voltage.
So if the potential is negative 0.76 volts
for the reduction half reaction,
it would be positive 0.76 volts
for the oxidation half reaction.
So now I've changed it to show
the oxidation half reaction,
solid zinc turning into zinc
two plus ions in solution,
and the loss of two electrons.
The Standard Oxidation
Potential for this half reaction
is positive 0.76 volts.
The next step is to add the
two half reactions together.
So here are all of our reactants,
and here are all of the products.
Notice how two electrons would cancel out,
and that gives us copper two
plus ions in aqueous solution,
plus solid zinc forms solid copper,
and zinc two plus ions in solution.
Since we were able to
get the overall equation
by adding the two half reactions together,
we should be able to get the
overall Standard Cell Potential
E naught of the cell,
by adding together the
standard potentials for
our two half reactions.
So E naught of the cell is equal to
E naught of the reduction half reaction,
plus E naught of the
oxidation half reaction,
which is equal to 0.34 plus 0.76,
or positive 1.10 volts.
So, the Standard Cell Potential
of our zinc copper cell
is equal to positive 1.10
volts at 25 degrees Celsius.
We can also calculate
Standard Cell Potential
using a slightly different form
of the equation that we just learned.
Remember that we flipped the sign
of the Standard Reduction Potential
to get the Standard Oxidation Potential,
which we plugged into this equation,
and were able to calculate
the standard potential of the cell.
Instead of flipping the sign ourselves,
and getting a Standard
Oxidation Potential,
we could use this new equation to just use
reduction potentials to calculate
the standard potential of the cell.
Notice that this new
equation has a negative sign
that essentially flips the sign of the
Standard Reduction Potential
for the oxidation process.
So, it accomplishes the same
thing that we did ourselves
in the first equation.
So to find the standard
potential of the cell,
we take the Standard Reduction Potential
for the reduction process,
and from that, we subtract the
Standard Reduction Potential
for the oxidation process.
So, this equation is a bit of a shortcut.
So when we plug in our
Standard Reduction Potentials
of positive 0.34 volts
and negative 0.76 volts,
the negative sign means we
end up with the same answer
we got before, a positive 1.10 volts.